game here tonight 107 105.
barnes has been spectacular
26 points 15 rebounds five assists
he's one of five raptors in double
figures
lakers have three in double digits
lebron holding on to it seven on the
shot clock
lakers are down by two lebron tough shot
oh he backs it in the bank is open in
canada
wow i mean he was defended that time
they were poked it free he goes and gets
it and then has the defender all over
him but somehow
finds the basket again shot clock is
about a second and a half ahead of the
game clock
lebron reached control of it lebron long
three
three bad rest
russ to tie the game hit the side of the
board
steal the inbound is first and foremost
on their mind but then about immediately
don't waste time if they get it in
follow immediately and they do get it
into a chuwa
and they still have it and they steal it
they steal it away it's russ
rust to tie the game he's got it
russ has got it we're tied
westbrook with point four
wow
they're gonna look to see if his toe was
on the line
but right now the call is a three by
russ but we'll look
at it again
well here's a good look at it they have
him trapped on the sideline and the
raptors just under under all that
pressure turn it over and russ comes
down and just oh that right foot is on
the line oh then he pulled it but he
pulled it but he didn't pull it
before he shot it
[Applause]
jaclyn's going to attack here he goes
all the way
by james lebron does it again
guarding the paint
another block by james
nearly stumbles does stumble but gets
fouled
[Applause]
lebron
won that second attempt by the lakers
goes in and gets the little floater to
go and then the defense when he's off
the ball he's like in a chase down
situation
that secondary defender he waits until
he sees it and he fly swats it